Thompson: Hello.
I'm Lilli Thompson,
and this is Building
Game Development Tools
with App Engine,
GWT, and WebGL.
So if you want to give
feedback during the session,
there's an official
SpeakerMeter page,
and there are also
some official hashtags,
if you want to
chat about it.
And I'll show this slide
again at the end,
if you don't get
the information right now.
So first of all,
the structure of this talk.
So I'll start out sort of
defining the problem space
and talk about why we need
game development tools
and why this particular
set of technologies
is a good fit
for this problem.
Then I'll show you
a demo of a couple of
really good motivating use cases
of tools on these technologies,
and then the second half
of the talk
is really
the meat of things.
It's the story of how
those demos were made.
There were all sorts of things
I sort of stumbled into
while I was developing,
and it's about sharing
that development process.
All right, so my background
is in console game development.
Before joining Google
as a software engineer,
I was the lead of tools
in central technology
at Secret Level Sega,
and game tools are something
I'm really interested in.
It's something I've done
for a lot of my career.
And when I came to Google
and started working
with App Engine and GWT,
I was super excited,
because these were
technological solutions
to very real game programming
programs I'd had in the past.
So the motivation
behind this talk
is really sharing
that thought with you.
This talk is for anyone
who's interested
in game development tools,
and I expect a lot of people
here to be interested
in browser games,
but actually the same
technologies and techniques
would work equally well
for mobile games
or even some tools
for console games.
So what are we
talking about?
What exactly do I mean
by game development tool?
Well, first, we should talk
about the type of data
we're going to support,
and the kind of assets
I'm talking about
are geometric assets.
So you have
big mesh data.
And the thing about
geometry data
is that it is just
so much bigger than the stuff
most people are used to
dealing with on the web.
You've got these big
binary files
and all this custom
logical data,
like rigging data
and trigger data
that doesn't have
a natural visualization
for your tools to use.
And on top of that, you've got
a lot of multimedia stuff
like sound effects, and video,
and that kind of stuff.
And on top of all that,
all this complicated
multimedia data
is connected together
in a big web.
So for instance,
your character assets
are going to
reference rigs.
They might also
reference meshes.
Your meshes might
reference materials.
Your materials might reference
textures and shaders,
even particle effects,
and sounds,
and all that kind of stuff.
So you've got complicated data
and complicated connectivity
between that data.
So you're going to need tools
to set all that up,
and when I say game
development tool,
probably the first thing on
a lot of people's minds
is level editors,
and level editors are
important and interesting,
but I just wanted to point out
that that's just one
of many types of tools
you might need.
You might need a way to set up
your material bindings
or define metadata
on your assets,
or if you have any sort of
skeletal animation system,
you might need
an HSM editor,
or if you have cut scenes
in your game,
you might need a cinematic
editor or logic editors.
There are all kinds
of opportunities
for different kinds of tools
on all scales.
So what's interesting about
tools programming,
with respect to
engine programming?
And I point this out,
because it's going
to affect your choice
of technology platforms
for one or the other.
And the thing about tools
is that in all likelihood,
they're part of the process
of making your game,
not part of the product
itself.
You're probably not shipping
your tools.
And what that means is that
for your game engine,
you might be willing to go
through all sorts of contortions
to wring every last bit of
performance out of the platform
that you possibly can,
and you might be willing
to sacrifice ease of development
for performance,
and that would likely be
a pretty bad decision
for designing your tools,
because if the number one
priority for your game engine
is performance,
then the number one priority
for your tools
is probably something else.
It's like rapid iteration time
or quick debugging.
So the two different uses
really do have different
technological priorities,
and a different technology
platform is often warranted,
and you see this
in the console games industry,
where it's a really
popular choice
to develop your game engine
in something really fast,
like C or C++,
and then do your game tools
in a different language
entirely,
that's optimized
for these other concerns.
For instance, it's really common
for console game studios
to write their tools in C#.
So if you've got
a browser game,
you might be thinking
to yourself,
"Well, my engine
is pretty small in scope,
and my data
isn't too complicated.
My team's pretty small.
Maybe I can do all the data
setup and authoring I need to do
just by hand authoring
a text file,
something really,
really simple."
If that's the scale
you're working on,
do you still care about
game development tools?
And the answer is yes.
Yes, you absolutely
should care.
It's true that web games
and mobile games
and all these new media forms
of games, on the whole,
are simpler today
than console games.
There's no doubt about that,
but it is amazing how quickly
the quality of the content
and the complexity are going up,
and the expectations of users
are going up along with them.
We saw this in the console games
industry about 20 years ago,
when game engines
were much smaller,
and the platforms had
a lot less power,
and you could pretty much
just hack things together,
and tools weren't
that big of a deal.
And then year after year,
the consoles grew, and grew,
and grew in power.
And before anybody really knew
how to solve these problems well
or acknowledge that they were
really important problems,
there was this dramatic
need for tools,
and the console industry
had to stop
and do a lot of catching up
and learning.
So you all should learn
from that.
And even if you're doing a game
in the browser or a mobile game,
and it seems simple today,
you will need tools,
and good tools will increase
the quality of your content
and the quality of your game.
I guarantee it.
Okay, so hopefully,
we're all on the same page
and think that developing tools
is a really important part
of developing a game,
but there are many different
platforms on which you could
write your tools.
So why would you use
these particular technologies?
So there are a couple of
key concerns
for your tools platform.
For one thing, you have to
consider the development skills
your team has
and where you want them to grow,
so what technologies
you think
might be important
in the future.
Sometimes, tools are a good way
to try things out.
Tools are all about UIs,
so you're going to need
some library with a lot of
widgets and text boxes,
and list boxes.
You'll need all that.
You also have to consider
setup overhead.
So every time a new team member
joins your team,
you're going to have to
get them set up
with a development environment
for your game.
And if it's a big complicated
install process,
that's a lot of work for you.
And also consider
that the trend in game art
has been to working
with offsite artists,
and that just underscores
the need for simplicity
of setup of your tools.
And then, as I mentioned,
debugging is absolutely
top priority.
So how does App Engine
fit into all this?
Well, App Engine is Google's
cloud services framework.
It's a set of APIs and tools
that help you
build an application
and a way to host them,
and I think the number one
reason you would want to use
something like App Engine
is for collaboration.
Really, the first reasons
that you might want to use
App Engine are just reasons
to put your tools
in the cloud,
and it's to have things
in a collaborative environment.
And we talked about the need
of ease of setup,
and so if you have
things in a browser,
there's no executable
for each user to install.
There are no command line
arguments
nor anything like that.
Setup is super easy.
Everybody knows how
to use a browser.
And then the thing that makes
App Engine particularly great
for this use case is that,
like I mentioned,
the tools are probably
not your product.
You're busy making your game,
so you probably don't have
a lot of time devoted
to buying hardware,
and managing
an authentication system,
and load balancing,
and all the kind of framework
and boilerplate you need
to get set up for a web app.
And one thing that App Engine
does really, really well
is provide a lot
of supporting APIs
and have a really good
new user setup.
So App Engine is great
for this use.
All right, so backends
and App Engine in the cloud,
but there are many ways
to write the frontend UI
for your web app,
so why would you use GWT?
So GWT is Google's framework
for making web apps.
It is a way to compile Java code
into JavaScript,
that is optimized for
different browsers.
And what's cool
about that?
Well, what GWT really gives you
is a scalable development
environment,
and what I mean by that
is that JavaScript is great
for rapid prototyping.
That's one of the things
it's really good at.
But if you have
a big application--
and tools are big applications--
that have a lot of moving parts,
going to live a long time,
a lot of people are
going to work on it,
you really benefit
from something
with a little more structure,
and that's exactly what
the Java of GWT gives you.
You have all the idioms and
patterns of Java there to use,
and yet it compiles
the JavaScript.
And on top of that, GWT has
a lot of really nice widgets,
if the ones that are there
don't suit your needs,
you can write your own,
and that's really easy,
and the whole thing
is open source.
All right, so backends
and App Engine, UIs and GWT,
but now we need a way
to render 3-D data.
So why would you use WebGL
for that?
Well, if you're a developer,
and you want to render 3-D data,
there are pretty much
two games in town
for working in a browser.
There's Molehill, which is
the 3-D functionality in Flash,
or there's WebGL.
That's pretty much the choice
you're making.
So why would you want
to use WebGL?
Well, you know,
it's nice to have an API
that doesn't require
any plugins.
So the browser just renders
WebGL natively,
and that's one less thing
to set up,
and we talked about how
ease of setup was important.
On top of that, you're
probably going to be mixing
a lot of Java and JavaScript
for your application,
because there are a lot of
cool JavaScript APIs
that are useful to
game development.
So having WebGL be in
JavaScript is really nice.
Everything is sort of together
in JavaScript.
You can use the browser
JavaScript debugging tools
that you're already using
for everything else,
not to mention there are some
really cool third party tools
for WebGL debugging,
for instance, WebGL inspectors,
one of them.
And on top of that,
it's just a really fast,
nice way
to do your drawing.
All right,
so that's the background.
Let me show you a demo of a tool
built using these technologies.
Whoa, why am I
black screening?
Aha.
All right, so this is my demo,
and what this is,
is just an asset
viewing tool.
So the idea here is that
you sync to a version control,
where you're probably checking
in all your assets,
and then you can see them
in the browser.
So you know, you have
a bunch of meshes.
You can sort of page
through your data.
This tool supports shaders,
textures, and meshes.
So if I look at
my thumbnails,
I can see that there's a bunch
of mesh data up at the top.
Then I have a bunch
of textures.
I have about 90 assets loaded
into this database right now,
and then shaders
down at the bottom.
And so the idea here is
that you can examine your data
to see that it is
what you expect.
And then over here
on the right,
I have a property grid
sort of thing
where I pulled out key
information about this object,
including its name
and its ID
and, of course,
its poly count.
So you can see this model here
is only about 2,500 polygons.
It's not particularly big.
But if I contrast that with
this character model,
this is about
130,000 polygons.
You can see
he's very, very dense.
You can sort of examine
his topology and wireframe,
which sort of helps you get a
handle on what's going on here.
This model is the biggest thing
I actually have in this database
right now.
It's about 200,000 polygons,
so dense that it's actually sort
of hard to parse in wireframe.
So it's cool that you can
just sort of look
at your stuff like that.
So this was the very first
tool, just an asset viewer tool
that I thought of
when I started trying to think
about doing game tools
in a browser.
And it was really
exciting to me,
because this is a tool
I actually wanted to write
at a previous game studio.
We had this idea that we wanted
to write this tool,
but we didn't have
the technology,
and the strong motivation behind
this is that often time,
big game studios,
a lot of little game studios,
or studios work together
as partners,
and it's really hard to see
what each other are doing,
so it's very common to have
three different artists
at three different developers
all making photorealistic rocks,
or crates, or grass textures,
or any of this kind of stuff
that's really common.
And just having a way
to view it in the browser,
which is what you can
do with App Engine,
is a really strong
use case.
Anyway, I was really excited
about just the asset viewer,
but I added a few more sort
of little features
that show off some things
that WebGL makes really easy.
So for instance, if I look
at this Android model,
this panel down here
at the bottom
shows his material bindings,
and this is all live editable.
And material binding tools
are something that you find
throughout the games industry.
It's something I've written
for a game studio before,
so it's a really nice realistic
use case,
and the idea is that his shader,
you can just go--
browsing here shows me
all the shaders
I have in my database.
I can set him up
as a red shader,
or I can render his surface
normals as RDB values,
or I've got a nice vertex
displacement shader
that makes him all noisy,
or my favorite
is the tune shader.
It makes him all cartoony.
And the cool thing
is that all this shader code
is live editable.
So if you click over
to the shaders tab,
you see the program
that's actually running
on this asset right now,
and on the left you have
the vertex shader,
on the right you have
the fragment shader.
And if I want to make him
a little redder, I can do so.
Or if think his outline
should be a little heavier,
I can change that.
So the thing about this,
this is the sort of thing that
WebGL makes super easy to do,
because all your shader code
in your programs,
you can pass them around
as strings in JavaScript,
and all your data
is right there in JavaScript.
So writing an interactive
shader editor,
which was something
that had been hard,
the last time I tried to do it,
is really easy with WebGL.
So it's a lot of fun.
And then, of course,
the texture channels
that are inputs to these shaders
area also live editable,
so I can just put him back
to a flat shader and show, like,
what if he were flat shaded
and made of brick
or something like that?
So it's all a really nice, easy
way to set up material bindings.
And then I had one more use case
I wanted to show you,
if you look
at this robot.
And the idea--
and this is a totally different
type of functionality--
but the idea here is that maybe
you've got 3-D assets,
but you want to make
a 2-D game.
So what you really need
is a way to take
a bunch of snapshots of
your mesh from different angles.
So you can compile them
down into a GIF
or however you're going
to store them,
and that's what this tool does,
and WebGL makes this very easy,
because you can just grab
what's on the current canvas
and upload that
to App Engine.
So for instance, here I select
a number of images,
a starting rotation,
an ending rotation,
and a resolution.
Well, he's actually big
for this display.
And then I can generate
a filmstrip view of this asset.
So you can see him sort of
progressively rotated.
And then I could take that,
and I could use it
in my 2-D game
in a nice way.
And this is the same technology,
the same idea behind this,
that thing used to make
these thumbnails over here.
So if I think this Android
would look better
with a different screenshot,
I can set it now.
So anyway, so that's
pretty much it for the demo,
and the idea here is that WebGL
makes material bindings
and shaders totally easy
and awesome and fun,
and App Engine does
this collaboration really well.
And so that's the basic premise.
All right, so back to the talk.
All right, so before I go on
to the second half of the talk,
just a tiny word of caution,
which is that
some of the features
that I used for that demo,
or that I'm about
to talk about,
require leading edge
browser support.
So I didn't want to give you
the false impression
that all these things
were available
in absolutely every browser,
because they're definitely not.
Now, wide availability
is important and good,
and it's important to note this,
but I think,
especially for this use case,
it's actually less important,
because you're developing tools
for people at your game studio
who already--
you're not trying to support
everybody on the web.
So the people at your studio
already need all kinds of
custom setup.
They need a 2-D editor,
and a 3-D editor,
and a copy of your IDE,
and a copy of your source code,
and so on, and so forth.
So saying browse to the tools
in a modern browser
is just not that big of a deal,
in my opinion,
but I wanted to note that.
All right, so let's talk about
the technology
that went into that demo.
So the basic building blocks
that I was trying to support
are shaders, textures,
and meshes.
That's the data you saw
in the tool.
And the basic things
I wanted to do with them
are I wanted to be able
to store them in the cloud,
use the cloud to process them
from an intermediate form
into a built form of the assets,
put them in a nice format,
where they're easily served
to the client,
and then render them
on the client.
So that's the box
around the problem
we're trying to solve.
So the very, very first thing
you're going to need to know
for any of this technology
is how you get from
the Java code in GWT
to JavaScript,
because, you know, I use
a lot of JavaScript APIs,
and WebGL itself
is a JavaScript API,
so you're going to need to know
how to go back and forth,
and the way you do that
is with something called
GWT JavaScript Native
Interface or JSNI.
And what that is it's
your all-purpose window
from GWT's Java
into the JavaScript world.
And what it looks like
to write a JSNI method
is that you write a Java method
with this native keyword
out front,
like you can see
on the slide,
and then it looks
to your Java IDE,
like the body of that method
is written in JavaScript
inside a comment, and you see,
like in the example method,
the argument passed in
is used by the same name
in the JavaScript, which is
how you sort of get data
from one side to the other.
And you can be as
object-oriented as you like
with JSNI.
You can either just inline
all your JavaScript straight,
or you can just call functions
that live in a JavaScript file
somewhere else,
or if you're being fancy,
and you want to do
a lot of stuff in Java,
you can make Java classes
that abstract out
a bunch of JavaScript
functionality,
and then treat them as objects
in your Java.
The amount of how you exactly
set that up is up to you,
but JSNI is the basic technology
behind it all.
All right, so if
that was step zero,
step one is like
you want to build a tool.
You've got some data.
What do you do with it?
So if you've got static data,
you can deploy it
just like you always deploy
static data.
You can just deploy it
along with your app,
the same way you put images
on your web pages.
So you can either have
big directories of textures,
and meshes, and shaders loose,
but that's not a great idea,
because you're going to be
doing a whole bunch of fetches,
and that's not particularly
efficient,
or a better idea is
to ball everything up
as resource bundles and then
serve them to the client
all at once.
All right, so resource bundles
sound like a good idea,
but how do you actually
handle that,
once you're working
with it on the client?
And the way you do that is
with the HTML5 file system API,
and what this is, is a way
to get a sandboxed
local file system
that your browser can use.
And it really is sandbox,
so you can't write all over
the client file system.
You can't write to my docs
or anything like that.
But within the sandbox, you can
read and write directories,
and you can read and write
files.
So you can do all sorts
of cool file systemy stuff,
and this is exactly
what you would want,
if you had a big bundle
of resources,
and you wanted to
expand it locally
and keep it organized
on your machine.
So this is what
it looks like to use,
the file system API.
Your way in is this function
request file system,
and you tell it whether
you want persistent
or temporary storage,
and you say how much you want,
and then you give it
a callback.
It gets called when the file
system is ready for you.
And then once that callback
is called,
you do pretty much
whatever you want.
A very reasonable thing to do
would be to check a hash
of local resources
against a hash of resources
on the server,
and see whether
there was syncing to do
and sync accordingly.
This is what it looks like
to write a new file.
So this is asking the root
directory of the file system
to get a file
by a specific name.
The function get file is used
for reading and writing,
so here we say we're creating
a new file.
You specify a callback
for what to do
when the writing is done.
Then you create one
of these blob builder objects,
which is how you get contents
into your file.
You put contents in it,
you write it,
and your callback
gets called.
Reading, very similar.
Here, we're asking the root
directory of the file system
to get a file by
a specific name,
create a file reader object,
specify a callback
for what to do when
the file is done reading,
then you read the file.
So pretty standard
file read/write API.
There's nothing tricky
about it at all,
but it's super useful,
and it's something
you will definitely want,
if you're dealing
with heavy resources.
All right, so we've got
everything in a resource bundle.
Now we're serving it
all together at once,
but that initial download
might be pretty slow,
because you're getting all
your resources at once.
So how do you
speed things up?
Well, the answer with
static data for speed
is pretty much caching,
caching, caching, caching.
And there are many
different types of caching.
It doesn't stop
at browser caching.
There are a ton of different
caching opportunities.
So much that, actually,
this would justify
probably a whole talk,
but I'm just going to go through
a lot of new things.
I'm not really going
to do it justice.
So if you have static resources
on App Engine,
you can set up their cache
expiration times
in your App Engine
web config file,
so that's a good thing to know
if you're serving
big sort of static resources.
Besides that, if you're
responding from a servlet
in such a way
that you have control
over the response headers,
there are a couple of
really important headers
you want to set.
So for instance,
max age says how long
something's going to stay
in the cache,
or cache control public
is a really good one.
It says that intermediaries
between the client
and the server can store
copies of your data.
So if you're willing to allow
that to happen,
that can speed things up
a whole lot for you.
And then on top of that,
just good caching technique,
you want to use something
called content fingerprinting,
which is where you make
the name of your file
a hash of its contents
or something that changes
when the contents change,
and you do that because values
are stored in the cache,
but with the name of the file
is the key.
So if you correlate the two,
then you can set
a very aggressive cache
timeout expiration on your data
and not worry about it,
your cache getting poisoned,
because the name will change,
and then it will get re-cached.
There's also this thing called
the HTML5 Application Cache,
which is five megs of local
cache data in the browser.
The way you interact
with App Cache
is through a manifest file
that says what to cache
and what not to cache.
The way you associate yourself
with the manifest file
is by referencing it
in your HTML.
And then the one thing
you need to know,
if you're doing this on App
Engine, or actually in general,
is that the file extension
or the file,
the cache manifest file,
has to be served
with the MIME type text
cache manifest.
So if you're doing this
in App Engine,
this is how you would
set up that MIME mapping
in your web to XML file,
and it can be
whatever file extension
you use to that MIME type.
And then this is what a cache
manifest file looks like.
It starts with the words
"cache manifest."
There's a section of
explicitly cache resources,
and these things are
going to stay cached
until the cache is
programmatically updated
or the manifest file
changes.
So you want to make sure that
these things are really static,
because they're going to stay
there for a while.
Then there's a section of things
that always bypass the cache,
always go the network,
and then you have
this extra bit of control,
where you can specify what to do
if your application
is offline.
You can specify
alternate resources.
Okay, so that's static data,
but we're talking about tools,
and that means you're
authoring data,
which means you need
some sort of dynamic solution
for storing data.
That's really the heart
of the problem.
So what do you do
with that?
So in App Engine, there are
two ways of storing data
I'm going to talk about.
There's Datastore and Blobstore.
So Datastore is the sort of
default option with App Engine.
It's a non-relational database,
so if you come to it
expecting a relational database,
you might be disappointed.
So you have to understand
what Datastore is.
It's really easy to use.
Properties on Datastore objects,
you can see them
in the Datastore console
of App Engine, very nice.
There are a bunch of frameworks
that work with it
like Objectify and JDO.
So it's great, except
for entities in Datastore
can only be up to a meg,
which is really not much
for a game today,
and that's where Blobstore
comes in.
So Blobstore entities can be
up to two gigs,
which is really nice,
and you upload them all
as a single blob,
but then when you want to read
or write them programmatically,
you have to do so
in one-meg chunks,
so it's a little bit
more opaque,
but it's a lot more efficient,
and you'll definitely need it,
if you're doing mesh data.
What you will
most likely do is
you will upload your data
into Blobstore,
and then you'll create
a Datastore wrapper
for each object that probably
abstracts out or pulls out
a few important properties
that you want to have
really available,
and then you'll store
the blob key of the blob,
and then you'll use
the two together.
If your application wants
to write stuff straight
into Blobstore, it can do so
using something called
the Blobstore file write API.
This is new
in App Engine 1.4.3,
so it's actually
a fairly new thing,
but it's really easy to use and
really important for game stuff.
So how do you use it is
that you get a file service
from a file service factory.
You have that service create
a new file with some type.
You open a write channel
to that file,
put your data in it.
You close it.
And then because most of
your interactions with Blobstore
will be by blob key,
you ask the service
to give you the key
of the blob you just made,
and hang onto that however
you're hanging onto
the rest of your blob keys.
So if you're uploading data
to Blobstore,
the process has a few steps,
and it might confuse you
the very first time you do it,
but it's really not hard.
The idea is that you're going
to have a form on your client
that needs to post data
somewhere
to get it into Blobstore,
and so you need a URL,
and you get that URL
from the Blobstore service.
So the Blobstore service
has a method, create URL,
which takes a handler,
which is going to get called
once the upload is done.
So the first thing your client
form does is request that URL.
It makes the post.
The handler gets called,
and then the trick
is that the first handler
can only return
a headers-only redirect.
It can't actually respond
to the client form,
so it has to redirect
somewhere else,
and then that somewhere
else can respond.
So maybe it sounds confusing,
but it's really not
much code at all.
The idea is here we are,
we're asking the Blobstore
service to create a URL,
and we're giving it
a handler to call,
once the upload happens.
The upload happens.
The post gets called.
The HTTP request object
that came in had information
about the blob keys that were
just created in the upload,
and you don't have
to know anything
about the format of the data.
The Blobstore service
will parse it out for you.
So you can ask it
to give you back a map.
You can do whatever
you want with that data.
So in this case,
I'm recommending you probably
make a Datastore object
to sort of keep track
of your Blobstore object.
Then you can redirect
somewhere,
and you can redirect
anywhere you want.
I usually redirect to the
get method on the same servlet,
just to keep everything
in the same file,
and then you can take
any parameters you want to pass
between the two and pull them
out into URL parameters.
So here I'm taking the I.D.
of the asset I just made,
putting it into the URL,
redirecting to get.
I pull out the parameters
I just put there, the I.D.,
and then I respond to
the client form with that I.D.
And so what it looks like to
the client form is upload blob,
get back asset I.D.,
which is very reasonable.
Okay, so that covers, like,
getting data into App Engine.
That's great, but there are
all sorts of transforms
you might want to do
on your data.
Game data is sort of fraught
with all these big data
transforms that you need to do.
So what's available
for that?
So there's several
different options,
depending on the type of data
you want to process.
So if you've got 2-D data,
you want the ImageService.
If you've got a bunch
of medium-sized jobs,
the task queue
is a really good choice.
And if you have really,
really heavy processing to do,
you might want
App Engine Backend.
So I'm going to talk
about each of these.
They're all sort of
service-side ways
you can do processing.
So the ImageService
is awesome.
It's just a really lightweight
image processing API.
It doesn't do a lot.
It's not particularly
feature full,
but the things it does, it does
really well and efficiently,
and they're probably the very
first things you want.
For instance, getting thumbnails
out of your data,
totally easy with ImageService
and cropping,
that kind of stuff.
So here's what it looks like
to use.
You get an ImageService from
the ImageService factory,
very typical App Engine API
pattern.
Then the way you actually
interact with the ImageService
is you give it a blob key.
The images it operates on
have to be stored in Blobstore.
So you get the key
to one of those images,
and it will return to you a URL,
and that URL is the way
you're going to manipulate
that image.
And so important to note
that URL's can take
a couple hundred milliseconds
to generate,
so you definitely
want to do this once
and then hang onto that URL.
But once it's generated,
it's really fast to use
that URL to manipulate it.
And then the way you actually
do image processing
is by appending strings
to the very end of that URL.
So this particular suffix says
scale the image down to
100 X 100 and crop it.
And this is really nice to be
able to do all this processing
via string manipulation,
because likely different parts
of your UI,
and your client might want
images at different resolutions
or stuff like that.
So it's really nice
to have that control.
All right, so the task here
is the way to do
parallel background processing
in App Engine.
It looks to the system,
each task, as it's executing,
looks like an HTTP request,
which is really nice,
because that means
that task queue tasks
scale the same way
that HTTP requests scale,
and App Engine is great
at handling
a whole bunch of
HTTP requests.
So for instance, you know,
your tasks can get distributed
across instances
and all that kind of stuff.
Every task can run
for ten minutes,
which may sound like a lot
or a little,
depending on what kind of
processing you're trying to do.
And by default you can have
100 per second,
or that's the max level
you can set it at.
So the sort of flow chart
I have on the slide here
illustrates how I'm using
the task queue
and what I think is
a really compelling use case,
when you're talking
about game data,
and that's the game data
build process.
So it's very common,
if you've got 3-D data,
to have your artist working in
some sort of 3-D authoring tool,
and then they export to
some sort of verbose
intermediate format
like OBJ or COLLADA,
or something like that.
But that's not what
your engine consumes,
because that would be
horribly inefficient.
So instead, you need
some sort of process
that builds your intermediate
data into binary data.
So you need to do all these
data processing operations.
So that's where something like
having tasks is good.
So for instance, in the tool
I just showed you,
the idea is it syncs to
my subversion repository,
gets all 90 assets at once,
and then farms out
a whole bunch of tasks
and builds them all in parallel.
So something like that,
if your data build needs fit
into ten minutes,
is a really nice thing.
So this is what it looks like
to actually set up a task queue.
You have a queue to XML file
that goes with all your other
App Engine config files.
You give it a name
and a rate
at which you want to allow it
to process,
and there are a couple of other
things I didn't put on a slide.
For instance, you can set
max number of concurrent tasks
you're willing to
let it execute,
if you want to keep an eye
on your processing,
your resource use.
And then here's what
it looks like to use.
You call it a queue by one
that you just put
in the queue XML file, by name,
and then you add tasks to it,
and each task takes a URL
that it's going to hit,
whether you're going to get
or post to that URL,
and URL parameters
you want to add,
and then each task executes,
calls to get,
and it does whatever
kind of processing
that method
is supposed to do.
So task queues are actually
a really big subject,
and I'm not really
doing them justice.
There's another talk
the hour after next
that's on nothing
but task queues.
So if you're interested
and want to learn more,
that's definitely
the place to go.
All right, so if ten minutes
did not sound like nearly enough
processing to you,
then App Engine Backends
might be a solution to
what you're trying to do,
and the idea here is
that App Engine,
standard App Engine
is really great at managing
a whole bunch of requests,
web requests,
and that's really good
for some things,
but not so great
for heavy processing.
So for instance, every request
starts with a client.
Those requests have
30 second timeouts.
Instances spin up and down,
based on load,
so you don't know
what's in memory
or what instance you're on,
all that.
So if you're doing
some really heavy work,
this is not a particularly good
environment to be in.
So for instance, in games,
it's very common to have
these big, big data
processing operations
that go on for, like, between
8 and 24 hours per build.
So if you're building
occlusion data, or AI data,
or light maps,
or something like that,
you might need, like,
a whole lot of processing,
and that's where App Engine
Backends come in.
So the idea here
is that you have an instance
with no request deadline.
You get more memory,
and you get an individually
addressable instance,
so you can keep talking
to the same instance,
and you can sort of think about
what's actually in memory.
And, again, backends
are a really big subject.
Next hour, there's a talk
on nothing but backends,
so I'm just sort of
mentioning it here.
But if you want
to learn a lot more,
go to that session.
All right, so we've got
our data stored in the cloud.
We've processed it
into some sort of form.
We know how to process it
into a form that we can use,
but what form
should that be?
So what's an interesting--
what's a good format
to store your data in?
We're talking about
serialization.
And so to me, the very
first thing I thought of
and what seemed pretty obvious
is that I wanted binary data,
so my meshes are all stored
in Blobstore as buffers afloat.
It was actually kind of
a surprise to me,
because I came from
the games industry first.
I'm not a web programmer
by default--
that binary data
is actually pretty hard
to request in a browser.
XML HTTP requests did not
have a binary response type
until this new specification
was recently added.
XMLHTTPRequest Level 2, which
adds two new response types:
array buffer and blob.
And so you're going to need
one of those,
if you're going to serialize
binary data.
So it was obvious to me
that I should use binary data,
but I was talking about this
with some other Googlers,
and the Google Body team
actually serializes their data
as UTF-8, which actually
blew my mind
that they could do that.
And so Google Body, if
you're interested in WebGL,
and you haven't--
you're not aware of Google Body,
you should definitely
check it out.
Not only is it
a really cool tool,
but it's a really cool use
of WebGL.
They have about 1.4 million
triangles in their mesh,
and yet, the whole thing is
pretty snappy to use.
And they get there by doing
a couple of really smart things.
They delta compress
their geometry,
so they have a bunch of
really small numbers.
They use variable length
encoding on their UTF-8,
so small numbers
are encoded small.
Then they configure their HTTP
to be sent GZipped,
which is something you can do
with your headers,
and some browsers can just
naturally decode it.
You don't have to do
any extra work on the client.
And then I believe the thing is,
it's the interaction of GZip
with the UTF-8 and all
the nice, small numbers.
It GZips really well,
and they get a fantastic
compression ratio.
They actually get about
3.5 times better compression
than I did with binary data.
It's really cool, so--
and then, of course,
everything is text,
so you can just parse it out
as a response text string,
and you can just use charCode@
to sort of parse out data.
It's a really
cool solution.
All right, so we figured out
a couple of options
for data formats.
We've got our data,
but how do you actually
request it from GWT?
So here we're talking
about Java code
that's going to allow you
to request this data
you just worked so hard
to set up.
Now, GWT has a really nice
class XML HTTP request,
which does a really good job
of making XML HTTP requests
easy and sort of abstract away
the details and all that.
But the problem is
that it doesn't have
a few methods you need,
if you want to request
binary data.
So what I needed to do
was to extend the XML HTTP
request class
to add two new methods,
which are get response,
the actual body of the response.
What's exposed right now
in the existing version of GWT
is response text,
which wasn't good enough,
because I've got
a big blob of binary data,
and it comes back
as a JavaScript object,
which is something
that the Java code
is not going to try
to interpret.
It's just going to get
thrown over
into JavaScript immediately.
And then you needed a method
to set the response tab
you were expecting to one
of these binary types.
So those are the only additions
you needed to make
to XML HTTP requests
to be able to do this.
And then what it looks like
to actually use
is you make one of
these objects.
You open a connection
to a specific URL.
You set the response type to
one of these new binary types.
You say what to do
when you're done.
So when it's done, you want to
load data with a response body,
which this load data function
is a native method,
which takes that JavaScript
object,
which I'm not trying
to interpret in Java,
and just passes it on over into
the JavaScript side of things.
And then here in the
JavaScript function,
I take my blob
that I got passed in,
and make a typed array
out of it.
So JavaScript had not had
a good way to represent
binary data until the typed
array specification came along,
and typed arrays
are a way to make,
a way to actually
get binary data.
They're a way to make views
on a data object.
So in this case, I'm saying
view this blob of stuff
as a float 32 array.
I could as easily say view this
as a UN8 array or whatever.
There are a bunch of different
types you can look at things at.
And then from there on,
you pass your buffer into WebGL,
and off it renders.
All right, so
where are we now?
We've stored our data.
We've processed it.
We've serialized it
and requested it.
WebGL is rendering it.
Everything is good.
One more thing
we need to know how to do
which is that we want to add
interactivity
to the application,
so we want to make sure
that it's rendering
as efficiently as possible.
So the way you do that is
with this request animation
frame API,
and the idea here
is that the old school way
to do animation in JavaScript is
with this function setInterval,
and what setInterval does
is that it takes a callback
and a rate,
and it just calls and calls
and calls at that rate.
And the problem with that is
that your JavaScript
is not necessarily in
a particularly good position
to know whether
that makes any sense.
So for instance, the client
could not have the resources
to fill the request
you're asking it to draw,
or, you know, worse still,
your WebGL could be
in a background tab,
so it might make no sense
to update your animation
at all, and yet,
setInterval will just call
and call and call,
because it's not
particularly smart.
So that's where Request
Animation Frame comes in.
Request Animation Frame
has a very similar format
in that you specify a callback,
and it'll attempt to call you,
but it puts the browser
in charge.
So the browser can take account
of all the conditions
that it knows about
and decide intelligently
whether you should be
called back.
So the API for Request
Animation Frame
is still stabilizing.
It's a very new thing.
So if you want to use it,
you want to use a shim layer.
You can see this is trying
to call it with a bunch
of different formats
and then falling back,
if none of those work.
And that's pretty much it.
So those are the major
technical sort of milestones
and hurdles that I needed
to overcome to make the demo.
That's sort of
what I learned.
And to recap, all right, so
if you've got static data,
you want to cache it,
and there are lots and lots
of different ways of caching,
and you should try to get
to know as many of them
as possible,
because they will help you
a lot.
If you are dealing
with resource bundles,
you're going to want
the HTML5 file system API,
a really useful way to get
a sandbox local file system.
If you've got dynamic data,
you're going to want Datastore
or Blobstore to store stuff
in App Engine.
You're probably going
to want a mix of both.
Probably every game asset
is going to be represented
by a Blobstore part
and a Datastore part.
If you're doing any kind of
processing or transforms
on your assets,
you're going to want a couple
of different APIs.
If you're doing 2-D stuff,
you might want the ImageService.
If you've got a bunch of jobs
that fit into ten-minute chunks,
you're going to want
task queues.
And if you've got really,
really heavy operations,
you might want App Engine
Backends.
And then for data formats
and serialization,
you can store your data
as binary
if you're using XHR Level 2,
or you can store it as UTF-8,
which can be efficient,
can be very efficient,
if you do stuff, smart stuff
like delta compressing your mesh
and GZipping your HTTP.
And that's pretty much it.
All right, so questions.
And if you want to give
feedback, again,
here's the SpeakerMeter link,
and there's some hashtags,
if you want to talk
about it on Twitter.
Any questions?
[applause]
man: Do you know if there's
any plans to make a wrapper
around the WebGL frontend
for GWT?
Thompson:
I don't know.
Yeah, I'm not sure about that.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
man: Just out of curiosity,
who are you building tools for?
Who are your users?
Thompson:
Me, personally?
man: Because it sounds like
you work at Google, right?
And I assume
this is your job.
Thompson:
Right.
man: Is Google
making games or recording...
Thompson: Oh, I got it.
I see what you're asking.
man:
...game publishers?
Thompson: Google is
interested in games,
so Google is really sort of--
has been over, very recently,
ramping up its interest
in the game community.
And so what my job title is,
I'm a Game Developer Advocate,
which means that I'm
an ex-game programmer
that talks to the game industry
or people interested in games
about Google technologies.
So the tools I made
are actually not
for any particular game.
Like, we don't actually
make content,
but the idea is to demonstrate
that these things can be done,
and get enthusiasm for them.
Because this is
all really new.
Actually, there isn't a lot
written about using App Engine
and WebGL or App Engine
and 3-D data, really.
So it's really just
to pioneer that stuff,
but no particular use case.
Anyone else?
Yeah?
man: So I know this might go
beyond the scope of the demo
that you've shown,
but have you put much thought
into how this might play nice
with a version control system?
I'm assuming that these assets
would all go up
to Google land, right?
Thompson: Yes.
So yeah,
that's a really good question.
So I think--
I would not recommend
that you would try to rewrite
your version to Drill System
in App Engine, unless writing
a version control system
is really your primary goal.
Which it usually isn't.
It's way bigger
than you think it is,
if you've never
tried to do it.
I think a very reasonable
workflow for a real game studio
would be to check your assets
into version control somewhere,
and then sync periodically.
If you're doing something
like the asset viewer tool,
the idea would be on change
you'd pull data in,
or nightly,
or something like that.
So I think you
definitely want to work
with external version control,
whatever that is,
and just sort of communicate
between the two.
Anything else?
All right.
Oh, yeah?
man:
Is it open source?
Thompson: So the question is,
is it open source?
And which thing are you
asking about?
man: [indistinct]
Thompson: No, not yet.
The code is a total disaster,
because I was hacking on it
right before I--
But I intend to make this a live
demo that people can use,
but it isn't yet.
Anything else?
All right, well,
thank you all for coming.
Have a good IO.